slobber getting shots but she's still a
stallion she don't even get a joke but
she's still smiling Megan the stallions
ripping Drake for that lyric and his new
track Circo Loco after suggesting she
lied about allegedly getting shot by
Tory Lanez what do you say to people
that still don't believe that you were
actually shot I don't think any of this
is for them like it's for me like I know
this happened to me Drizzy and 21 Savage
dropped their joint album her loss
Friday which features the song with the
controversial lyric this lava getting
shots but she's still a stallion she
don't even get a joke but she's still
smiling yeah although the rapper doesn't
say Megan's full name he kind of doubles
down a few lines later with Shorty said
she graduated she ain't learning enough
Play the album track one okay I heard
enough some background Megan graduated
from Texas Southern University in 2021
and track one of her 2020 album good
news shots fired a diss track many think
is aimed at Tori pull snitch I ain't
never went to the police with no names
hours after Circo Loco dropped Meg
caught wind of it and shared her
feelings on Twitter writing in part
quote stop using my shooting for clout
since when is it cool to joke about
women getting shot people attack me
y'all go up for it I defend myself now
I'm doing too much every time it never
ends and this did not happen until I
came out and said I got shot they
reached out and said you know Megan is
ready to talk back in April Megan spoke
to Gail King about the incident on CBS
mornings so I'll get out the car and
it's like everything happens so fast and
all I hear is this man screaming is he
said dance he start shooting and I'm
just like oh my God like he shot a
couple of times I think she was just fed
up with the narrative that's out there
she wanted to she wanted to control her
own story were you afraid for your life
at that time I'm really scared because I
had never been shot at before Tori was
charged with one felony count of assault
with a semi-automatic weapon and another
count of carrying a loaded unregistered
firearm in a vehicle he's pleaded not
guilty and a trial is set to begin
November 28th how has your life changed
since you were shot
I feel like my anxiety is worse
I feel like
my relationship with people is
it's it's gotten very cold because I'm
not as trusting as I used to I was going
to ask you is it hard for you to trust
people
like I got this wall and I don't want to
make any friends you know this is what's
so sad to me is that there's videotape
there's a medical report there is a
police report and there are still people
that are trolling Megan online and I
think she ignored it for as long as she
could I really do believe that and then
I think it just got to her and so for
better or worse she said I want to say
something hopefully people will believe
her but it but now she can at least say
I stood in my truth and I told and I
told my story
[Music]